the only thing that you have to do with
this is understand that taking the value
of the conversation and making it
actionable for you is like really
important meaning all that's happening
right now is just Deja Vu to the two
chapters of my career the mid 90s and
the mid-2000s where you know you're
sitting on information that's a hair
early right we know that this is not
like what people are talking about at
scale yet but it's an inevitable there's
nobody in here that isn't going to be
living in a significant blockchain and
AI World in 10 years this is important
because for a lot of you in 10 years
you're either in the prime or in the
precipitous of your biggest job ever to
finish it off please use the energy of
this and get real serious an hour or two
a day or a week please give me two hours
a week of actually tasting this for
real like get in it get in it because
this will set you up for a lot of
success either on offense or at least
have the defense to keep you at the
perch that you're already at because
this is how people get blown out